did you both get like uh set up and and
[ __ ] forced to fight like as soon as
you were in yes it's called toh you have
you have to test your heart because um
you they want to see if you're [ __ ] or
knife if you're [ __ ] don't take your
food yeah i fought the second day as
soon as i said so yeah and did you win
your fights yeah well actually matter of
fact yes it did uh there was a kid there
was a kid that that they he stole a
maserati and he thought he was the [ __ ]
and um they said hey i like him over you
and when they say that when they say
that they're when they say that it's
called
okay it's fighting so yeah so there's so
it's called instigating right so it's
like you know i he says i like you over
me
i don't know and that's and that's it
and i don't know but see we're all good
people though and that's around a bunch
of you know people and they want and
they're like oh
yeah and i'm like okay i'm gonna see
about you
and then you're gonna have that yeah and
then he asked me he wants to he wants a
friendly a friendly fade
and i said i don't do friendly faces
friendly friendly fate is when you you
fight
but he wants to be friends out friends
after that so look i'm like i don't do
that so i'm like if we're gonna fight
we're gonna fight so i said i'm gonna
see about you i waited till night and
when i waited tonight i saw him brushing
his little waves he had waves brushing
his hair i was gonna stall you know i
punched a little bit you know a little
sparring session in the bathroom stall i
came out
i walked very slowly i did a smooth and
then i went
and i punched him in his eye and he had
a black eye i mean it was stopped right
there the stab member stopped and
everything he's like well and then his
homework that was bigger than me he said
man that was a fair minute you trying to
find me i said what's up what do you
want to do about it you feel me so they
didn't like me at first but the next day
they when i woke up like you know what
i'm adapting you're a man bro you did
what you got to do so yeah
other than that i popped off on another
kid because he came in on some
double-sided thing he got popped off on
one dorm and when he came in here he
tried to snitch on the other dorm and um
they put some honey buns on top of his
head i want to go grab some food and um
he was sitting on the couch honey buns
on top of his head they like money it's
like money on top of this right right
yeah so you know so that means if you
kick them
honey buns or mp3 player they could play
music right and that's they're not like
actually putting on his head they're
like